♪ ♪
>> Bret: ONE OF THE WORLD’S
MOST INFLUENTIAL BUSINESSMEN IS
TAKING ON THE GOVERNMENT OVER
ITS CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWN.
ELON MUSK SAYS ON TWITTER HE HAS
REOPENED HIS FACTORY IN
CALIFORNIA IN VIOLATION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ORDERS.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT
JONATHAN HUNT HAS THE LATEST.
>> AFTER RAILING FOR WEEKS
AGAINST CALIFORNIA’S
RESTRICTIONS ON MANUFACTURING,
ELON MUSK RESTARTED PRODUCTION
AT HIS CALIFORNIA PLANT ON
MONDAY, TWEETING "I WILL BE ON
THE LINE WITH EVERYBODY ELSE.
IF ANYONE IS ARRESTED, I ASK
THAT IT ONLY BE ME."
WITH THE TESLA FACTORY SHUTDOWN,
REVENUE OBVIOUSLY IS FALLING
FAST.
WHILE OTHER AUTO COMPANIES ARE
REOPENING PRODUCTION LINES.
AMONG THEM, TOYOTA AND INDIANA
TODAY.
GENERAL MOTORS, FORD, AND
FIAT CHRYSLER AND MICHIGAN
EITHER LATE THIS WEEK OR EARLY
NEXT.
OFFICIALS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
CALIFORNIA, LIKE MANY OF THE BAY
AREA, ARE MOVING SLOWLY, ARGUING
TESLA FIRST NEEDS TO SHOW IT CAN
OPERATE SAFELY.
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
BACK TO THOSE HEALTH OFFICIALS
BUT SAID HE BELIEVED PROGRESS IS
BEING MADE.
>> MY BELIEF AND HOPE AND
EXPECTATION IS AS EARLY AS NEXT
WEEK THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
RESUME.
>> TESLA HAS FILED A LAWSUIT IN
FEDERAL COURT ACCUSING THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT
OF OVERSTEPPING FEDERAL AND
STATE RESTRICTIONS.
WHILE ELON MUSK ONCE AGAIN TOOK
TO TWITTER SATURDAY, WRITING
"FRANKLY THIS IS THE FINAL
STRAW.
TESLA WILL MOVE ITS HQ AND
FUTURE PROGRAMS TO TEXAS/NEVADA
IMMEDIATELY."
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLYWOMAN AND
FORMER LABOR LEADER FIRED BACK
WITH THIS TWEET.
MUSK REPLIED MESSAGE RECEIVED.
SAYING THAT WHILE MUSK MAY WANT
TO MOVE PRODUCTION IT WOULD COST
A FORTUNE AND TAKE ANYWHERE FROM
12 TO 18 MONTHS.
MUSK CERTAINLY HAS THE MONEY,
THOSE SAME EXPERTS ARGUE, BUT